[Musik]
und das wird meist so eine andere das
buch stellt die kann leuchten
hey leute was gedacht vorher zu bekommen
bei einem neuen video ja heute ich hoffe
natürlich euch hier ist gut heute ein
video auf das ich mich schon sehr lange
sehr freue weil das wirklich lustig für
uns selber weil es wird sich durch diese
produkte einiges in unserer wohnung
ändern und zwar habe ich das irgendwann
machen moment ich muss kurz zu bestehen
ich hoffe dass irgendwann in den
kommentaren gelesen unter dem video zehn
kostenlose produkte im test als und hopp
kommentar und zwar alex macht doch mal
eine idee produkte von witzig fand gute
idee habe direkt mal losgelegt gesucht
gesucht gesucht und am anfang habe ich
direkt zwei drei coole sachen gefunden
dann allerdings irgendwie gar nichts
mehr also es war gar nicht mal so leicht
coole sachen zu finden
wir haben auf jeden fall jetzt vier
produkte die ich euch zeigen werde
dieselbe interessant sind und auch
lustig ich hab's ja mal kurz
zusammenfassen wir haben einmal eine
lampe die man mit fernsteuerung steuern
kann und dann halt eine farbe einstellen
kann jetzt nichts besonderes dann haben
wir led toilet also ein led dingen für
eine toilette dann leuchtet die ganze
toilette dann haben wir ein led
duschkopf superwichtig und noch
irgendwas was mir dass ich ein feld also
ich würde sagen wir packen das jetzt
erst mal aus und schauen wenn es hier
dabei bin muss man ihr wisst ja da ich
so viel bestelle ich musste mal die
sachen vorher schon aufbauen um zu
gucken was da drin ist deswegen ist das
ihr zum beispiel als auch schon offen
als erstes haben wir hier eine lampe bzw
eine led lampe die kann man rand
schrauben wo man will
und die kann in verschiedenen farben
leuchten das gute ist wir haben dazu
eine fernbedienung das ganze hat glaub
ich sogar nur 2 euro gekostet also ich
bin mal gespannt wie lange die halbe
wird da werde ich euch dann auch in
weitere news videos gerne ein kleines
update zu geben weil ich kann mal kurz
sagen ich habe ja letztens bei den
kostenlosen sachen mal dieses grüne
iphone ladekabel dazu bestellt ist es
was so näher und nun leuchtet das schon
kaputt also so viel zur qualität
trotzdem habe ich hier gedacht wir haben
ja immer noch die zweite lampe die
kaputte ist könnte man doch eigentlich
machen oder
doch geil aus dem windows fassung 1 das
was auf jeden fall kannst du so
badewanne mit roter stimmenden genau
bisschen romantisch muss man ja nicht
groß was zu erklären
das haben wir schon mal als nächstes
genau das hier habe ich leider auch
schon aufgemacht weil ich hatte gar
keine ahnung etwas ist das ich dachte
erst das wäre eins meiner 1 euro jung
produkte ich habe mich kennt er
wahrscheinlich ist so eine kleine jetzt
nicht sagen konkurrenz aber da kann es
auch einen möglichen start bestellen da
wird es bei zwei oder drei passt zu
geben
ich teste 1 euro jun produkt wird das
hier ist im led fürs klo also dass
klemmt man wie so ein kloß stein wenn
man ja so ne ins klo und das kann wohl
leicht und das war sogar in einem tipp
von einem zuschauer da hat mal in die
kommentare geschrieben wir haben zu
hause einen led leuchte fürs klo und ich
dachte mir wer hat denn ernsthaft so
eine scheiße ist so komplett würde ich
jetzt keine videos machen und einen
schrott teilnahme an ausmachen würden
wir uns das wollen nein oder wir kommen
dann auf so eine idee sich so was zu
kaufen also hier steht das geht nur im
dunkeln wenn also ersten bewegungssensor
dran über eines bewegung aufnimmt weißt
du dann geht es an für zwei minuten
können wir gleich mal ausprobieren ich
bin gespannt ob es klappt mein
lieblingsprodukt feiert jetzt schon und
zwar haben wir hier einen led duschkopf
also die qualität ist auch in ordnung
ist das plastik 626 teur
aber ja genau und so sieht übrigens das
bild aus den habe ich bestellt und das
ist für uns gepfiffen
der hat aber eine top-bewertung ach so
kummer und erleuchtet wenn wasser
durchkommt grün rot und blau
gleichzeitig so weit ich weiß vielleicht
kann man da auch eine spezielle farbe
dann einstellen
wir werden sehen also das ist das dritte
produkt und jetzt kommen wir noch zum
vierten
da habe ich extrem lange für besucht
einfach weil ich nichts anderes mehr
gefunden hat ich dachte er die werden
drogen denn oder so
wie das verpasst aber er ist ganz
einfach ein led streifen für den
fernseher also dem wachstum im fernseher
kam es dann um den fernseher und kleben
und hast dann immer wenn der fernseher
alles so einen leichten led scheint um
den verein herum wenn man auch mal
testen auch die das lohnt das ganze war
gratis also ich musste nur im versand
bezahlen
deswegen bin ich ganz nah ich würde
sagen wir geben einen smart und fangen
mit der leuchter und anfangen dann würde
ich sagen kommt man mit so leute wir
sind jetzt hier im bad
hier habe ich die lampe wird ganz
wichtig strom aus stellen bevor man die
wechselt wir haben jetzt warten die
softbox an mit akku betrieben wollte das
sei aber leider die verfassung deswegen
müssen das jetzt hier machen
ich weiß das ist jetzt nicht die
professionellste lampe aber werden noch
schauen wie's aussieht
okay das ist schon mal drin dazu kommen
wir dem strohmann machen
ich weiß aber dass nur alte leute wir
befinden uns erzählen unserem neuen bad
tut mir leid für dieses stärker steigen
und das ist jetzt erledigt und ich will
zeiten bis alles eis oder julius ist so
hier seit sie ferne liebe und wir können
das jetzt grün machen oder wenn doch
nicht so gelb blau pink lila und man
kann es auch aus waren und wieder an
machen kannst du auch sie ganz nah
und jetzt wo alles zu krass oder
das neue sony später ein bisschen zu
sehr hat die lichter und drittens also
das eigentlich mainz oder ein gutes
feature wenn wir jetzt noch da andere
lampen das wäre gut auch nochmal
verändert doch eines klar wir bleiben
gebracht also die lampen hängen
ich finde es mal so und jetzt machen wir
direkt weiter in bar und zwar mit diesem
chlor led da bin ich jetzt bin ich mal
gespannt ob das funktionieren kann hat
immer so das klima jetzt hier dran
und jetzt muss ich eigentlich dass ihr
grund machen und jetzt auch ziehen und
dann ist das ergebnis spürbar fall
scheiterte aus weißrussland oder das ist
jetzt zwei minuten an und dann geht es
wieder aus also wir sehen uns wieder
wenn es aus ist und dann spielen wir
noch mal auf also okay okay leute wären
es hier komplett das licht ausgemacht
jetzt ist nur von ronis led dinge die
toilette jetzt gleich noch und dann
gleich noch der durchkommt dann haben
wir ein ganzes led war dass man auch mal
besser du musst hier professor machen
des bewegungsmelders basis wenn wir uns
hier den markt ist vielleicht schlauer
comazo weiße weil du gehst dann so im
stimmt wissen also zumindest ist das bei
hitze und und dann begegnet er kann dann
selbst man sich jetzt hier drauf dass
ich bin schon wirklich mit dem video ist
bevor wir weiter machen ganz wichtig
kanal abonnieren locker aktivieren jeden
tag manchmal gibt's hier neues video
schreibt sich hinter die mauer dann
lassen wir jetzt direkt den duschkopf
machen wir waren ja alles und dann hat
die hamburger schwamm hier bin ich jetzt
wirklich mal gespannt und dann ist alles
led ich muss jetzt erstmal den normalen
moskau verstorben
aber ich brauche das passt jetzt immer
noch so ein gummi ding braucht das
musste man abnehmen
und jetzt kann man perfekt und es müsste
schon jetzt haben sie jetzt auf jeden
fall befestigt weist es ums geld
[Musik]
also ich würde sagen der strahl ist auf
jeden fall besser als bei unserem alten
duschkopf das ist einfach dran lassen
oder warum jetzt sagt
[Musik]
so
also das muss man ja wirklich sagen ja
es funktioniert alles einwandfrei bis
jetzt komplett daumen nach oben kann ich
euch alles empfehlen würde das führt zu
hause haben wollt kauft sich halt okay
die ersten leute haben schon mal genial
das einzige was jetzt noch fehlt ist
dieses fernseher led das würde ich jetzt
mal bei mir am fernseher installieren
ich habe einen fernseher im zimmer
jahren vielleicht werden soll weil wir
keinen brauchen das ist jetzt mehr so
gerade jeder produktionsraum für die
videos und ich würde sagen jetzt
gekommen damit das heißt wir haben ihnen
den usb-anschluss den kann ich jetzt
gleich einfach in den fernseher stecken
und dann sollte dieses led-band hier
leuchten
ich habe das kann man direkt an bringen
kiel besuchen
das muss man doch nicht die ausbeute da
kann man hier ist auf jeden fall die
klägerseite in der tat etwas staubig und
dem fernseher
also ich hatte schon länger nicht mehr
puts ein das bringt nicht projekt man
diesen staub werden von dir und jetzt
muss ich das hier abreißen wollte man
muss leider sagen das ist nicht
besonders lang
naja wahrscheinlich hätte ich es auch
noch in einer längeren größe bestellen
können deswegen bringen wir das jetzt
mal hier oben an
noch müssen die mitten im flug gibt es
nicht und das sollte er es eigentlich
gut aussehen deswegen machen wir
maschinen dunkel ich bin mal gespannt ob
es funktioniert
jetzt ist hier wieder auspacken
hey wieso ist es jetzt wieder an
also ich glaube von besonders hoher
qualität ist das nicht aber kann es nur
in einer form gelöst und ich hab das
glaube ich in orange gestellt also es
läuft ja so leicht aber wenn alles sieht
schon eigentlich ganz
es gibt halt auf welche die können sie
genau die farbe von dem bild an neben
dem fernseher das oft geil aber ich weiß
also ganz entspannt weil wir machen
jetzt noch einmal aus kommerz wieder aus
jetzt machen wir noch mal an
doch also und auch hier zufrieden geiles
video also so zufrieden war ich glaube
ich noch nie mit einem video leute ganz
wichtig schreibt weitere ideen für
videos in die kommentare geben dann nach
oben aber nicht den kanal glocke
aktivieren
jeden tag um 19 uhr neues video ich kann
nicht mal kurz sagen was ist noch für
videos in zukunft geben wird wir machen
bald noch ein paar richtig mainz immer
ein bisschen um nur mit milchprodukten
also es wird meist habe so eine andere
das bestellte kann leuchten und so
weiter also da wird noch einiges cooles
kaum technik gadgets haben wir auf
demnächst das war's zog man ins taxi
haut rein